so we have a question here on p values
it says evie read an article that said
six percent of teenagers were
vegetarians but she thinks it's higher
for students at her school to test her
theory evie took a random sample of 25
students at her school and 20 percent of
them were vegetarians so just from this
first paragraph some interesting things
are being said
it's saying that the true population
proportion if we believe this article of
teenagers that are vegetarian we could
say that is six percent
now for her school there is a null
hypothesis that the proportion of
students at her school that are
vegetarian so this is at her school that
the true proportion the null would be
it's just the same as the proportion of
teenagers as a whole so that would be
the null hypothesis and you can see that
she's generating an alternative
hypothesis but she thinks it's higher
for students at her large school so her
alternative hypothesis would be the
proportion the true population parameter
for her school
school
is greater than six percent and so to
see whether or not you could reject the
null hypothesis you take a sample and
that's exactly what evie did she took a
random sample of 25 students and you
calculate the sample proportion and then
you figure out what is the probability
of getting a sample proportion this high
or greater and if it's lower than a
threshold then you will reject your null
hypothesis and that probability we call
the p-value the p-value
is equal to
the probability that your sample
proportion
and she's doing this for students at her
school
is going to be greater than or equal to
20
if you assumed that your null hypothesis
was true
so if you assumed that the true
proportion at your school was six
percent vegetarians but you took a
sample of 25 students where you got 20
what is the probability of getting 20 or
greater for a sample of 25
now there's many ways to approach it but
it looks like she is using a simulation
to see how likely a sample like this was
to happen by random chance alone evie
performed a simulation she simulated 40
samples of n equals 25 students from a
large population where six percent of
the students were vegetarian she
recorded the proportion of vegetarians
in each sample here are the sa sample
proportions from her 40 samples
so what she's doing here with the
simulation this is an approximation of
the sampling distribution of the sample
proportions if you were to assume that
your null hypothesis is true
and it says below
evie wants to test her null hypothesis
which is that the true proportion at her
school is six percent versus the
alternative hypothesis that the true
proportion at her school is greater than
six percent where p is the true
proportion of students who are
vegetarian at her school and then they
ask us
based on these simulated results what is
the approximate p-value of the test and
they say the sample result the sample
proportion here was 20 we saw that right
over here
well if we assume that this is a
reasonably good approximation of our
sampling distribution of our sample
proportions there's 40 data points here
and how many of these samples do we get
a sample proportion that is greater than
or equal to twenty percent
well you can see this is twenty percent
right over here twenty hundredths and so
you see we have three
right over here that meet this
constraint and so that is 3 out of 40.
so if we think this is a reasonably good
approximation we would say that our p
value
is going to be approximately 3
out of 40 that if the true population
proportion for the school were six
percent if the null hypothesis were true
then approximately three out of every 40
times you would expect to get a sample
with 20 or larger being vegetarians and
so three fortieths is what let's see if
i multiply both the numerator and the
denominator by two and a half this is
approximately equal to i say two and a
half because to go from forty to a
hundred and then two and a half times
three would be 7.5 so i would say this
is approximately
7.5 percent and this is actually a
multiple choice question and if we
scroll down
we do indeed see approximately 7.5
percent right over there